husbands who complain about having zero
sex have no idea how the female sex
drive actually works and the complaining
makes it much worse
my favorite thing is when couples come
in and they haven't had sex in a year
and I ask why and she looks at him and
says because he hasn't asked and he says
well I kind of hinted and you just never
seemed interested and she says well when
was the last time you've spent time with
me well why would I spend time with you
if you're not having sex with me and
that right there is exactly the spiral
women after one year their sex drive
switches from bonding with you mode to
long-term stability and mate retention
if you have given her the adequate
emotional bonding and if she has decent
enough secure enough attachment to
receive that bonding her sex drive will
go way up because her brain says keep
this man around and have as many of his
babies as I can we must have 15 babies
in the next week that's what her brain
will say and I've seen couples I've
worked with couples in their 60s who
come in and sorry for this mental image
but they come in having very little sex
and they leave after a few sessions
having sex three or four or five times a
week in their 60s because they improve
their actual emotional intimacy which
leads to better non-sexual physical
intimacy which then leads overwhelmingly
to sexual physical intimacy it should
begin in your emotional bonding and
connection it will drive her sex drive
through the roof and she will not only
be receptive to you she will be chasing
you through the house
yeah you had another tweet that said at
about six to 12 months into a
relationship the female sex drive
switches from attraction and bonding to
long-term stability that means emotional
intimacy trust and predictability many
couples lack these three things so her
sex drive tanks neither person fully
gets why
so many women that I work with do not
understand how their own sex drive works
I I have clients who come in and they
say Adam I don't know why I don't have a
high sex drive I just feel like my
husband is mad at me for not having sex
with her but I just kind of don't want
to what's the problem and I say well you
don't want to because he's not doing
what he's supposed to be doing as your
husband they say oh thank you for saying
that I say okay well what would it take
well I don't know just like maybe more
time together and so we run through a
list of exactly like 12 to 15 things of
what spending time together should look
like and then we give him a measurable
list of do this do this do this do this
often this amount of time this level do
this and they do it for a week or two
and all of a sudden her sex drive goes
through the roof and they're very happy
um so
I remember reading in Jonathan Heights
the happiness hypothesis about the
passionate and companionate uh two
styles of of it's not quite attachment I
think it's attraction perhaps
is there an equivalent for men
for these emotional intimate bonding
like this yeah so you've said that with
women around about six to 12 months the
the arousal response occurs due to
different
stimulus stimuli is there an equivalent
for men
there is
um
yes okay here's what it mostly is I'm
trying to frame it people don't usually
ask that so let's talk about this the
male sex drive typically works if we
have resources then we want to go
reproduce because we have enough
resources to protect whatever would
happen if we reproduced that's a cheap
way of saying it but the male brain has
to say look if I'm going to throw
endless resources at something I need to
make sure it's actually going to be
sustainable and that everything is going
to continue the way it needs to so if a
woman is betraying him if a woman is
completely
anti-maternal usually if a woman is
actively hurting him and attacking him
or if his stress level is overwhelmingly
high from his environment that's where
the man's sex drive typically goes down
it takes pretty significant factors of
this is not sustainable for a man's sex
drive to tank that hard it's it's tough
not impossible but tough I do know that
bonding through oxytocin actually and
she helps men achieve faster erection
and more lasting erections so oxytocin
is very important for men it's the
bonding hormone you get through
emotional intimacy but it is very
important but men can still endure
without it it takes a lot to turn off
the male sex drive we're a little bit
more simple creatures I think we are
comes to that what was what was it that
you taught me about the role of
vasopressin for men during sex so the
research shows that when men have
orgasms it works a little bit different
than when than how women have orgasms
women will have orgasms and they their
orgasm happens largely due to an
overwhelming supply of oxytocin that
causes massive constrictions through the
uterus and same same hormone that causes
um labor and birth we have a synthetic
version that we use called pitocin that
actually induces labor it's synthetic
oxytocin and women flood with that
during sex and that's what leads to one
orgasm which then leads to another and
then leads to ten and then leads to her
having a toe tag because she's died but
that's what it's supposed to be men have
one orgasm if they get any and oxytocin
may or may not affect the male brain as
much as it does the female brain it
seems to more be there to move the semen
along and he may Bond a bit with you
through oxytocin but men have far more
receptors for vasopressin vasopressin is
the hormone responsible for bonding when
you achieve a mission together you solve
a problem together you accomplish a goal
together you know men are goal oriented
who could have predicted that if he
accomplishes in sex with you and says
we're going to give you 10 orgasms most
women respond by saying no let's not do
that or why the arbitrary number he is
actually setting a goal with you wants
to achieve it and wants to high-five
with you and that is actually going to
bond him to you more than his own orgasm
is going to bond him to you if you go
with him and accomplish a mission
together
that's going to be what does it so a
failure of cross-sex mind reading in
that women wouldn't understand why they
would create some arbitrary number of
this is how many pumps you're going to
give me before we finish or this is how
long it's going to last for this is how
whatever else it is
saying that to a woman is unlikely to
cause her to have
any additional bonding with you but to a
man placing some sort of challenge in
front of him that he can get to achieve
whilst also having sex sex being good
but achieving this okay so this together
as a team together as a team you achieve
that by the way that's the vasopressin
piece you your brain says we did this as
a team what else can we do as a team too
and it makes his brain say I want to
work with you to solve other problems as
well because now I have proven that you
are a good trustworthy Ally in my life
that's the key right there what is the
takeaway lesson for women in the bedroom
with regards to vasopressin and
maximizing that for men stop not asking
for orgasms stop just letting it not
happen stop just laying there and
closing your eyes and thinking of
England actually engage in it that's
right I'm okay I'm okay ladies that are
listening if you want to close your eyes
and think of England that's actually
certified by me as something that's
totally okay if she can say hey look
this is what does it for me help me
achieve this and I will be your best
friend uh and they do it and then tell
him that that was amazing and how great
it was and do it but mean it don't fake
it don't be don't be pretend do it and
accomplish it together and then
celebrate the win together that's the
other thing is most women are so
embarrassed when they have an orgasm do
it embrace it and celebrate the win
together as a team and man you guys are
both have a much better time I'll just
tell you that
what in your time looking at the sex
slides of men and women were the most
common reasons for women struggling to
achieve orgasm
usually because they have their own
attachment issues so they're either
avoidant where they fear oxytocin so
you'll see them pull away during
physical intimacy they will prefer to be
facing away from you during sex so that
there's not physical emotional intimacy
they will pull away after sex get their
clothes on really fast and try to pull
away and they're not comfortable with
that closeness that's one big one that I
work on as oxytocin aversion usually
through avoidant attachment the other is
anxious attachments so they're massively
insecure they are doing the sexual act
to try to please their partner it's not
like they're a prostitute they're trying
to make their partner feel good and feel
joyous and loving so their partner won't
abandon them they are trying to be
useful to their partner sex then is a
performance it's an act to make their
partner feel good they are absolutely
not focused on their own sex drive at
all what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full
episode and don't forget to subscribe
peace
foreign
[Music]